it feels like the old vet is actually a
man I'm the young lad is a [ __ ] no
offense but he kept talking about mental
health and BS the old man served in
World War two and did not complain once
if he can't handle death in a ward and
don't go in the army I don't know where
to start all this
hi my name's T Nichols I'm a veteran
six months ago I sat down with an older
veteran on the gap when soldiers come
back home so on Locksley the wrong way
you're already in fight mode it's been
twelve years I'm still fight mode number
well you've been through quite a lot not
yet we compared our stories and our
lives and it's created a massive
response online there's questions that
we had and the gap that I don't want to
answer because I knew they'd trigger me
they call it PTSD post-traumatic stress
disorder I don't like to call it
disorder Ally it's like calling
something of the disease it is an injury
now going forward I'm in a much better
place where I'm happy to talk about
anything now it's like well me answering
those questions could help someone else
how can you say you suffered major
mental health and then you say you
missed the firefights
because as a good question actually
mental are [ __ ] aah growls is trauma
to the brain PTSD is trauma to the brain
and that trauma is caused by a traumatic
event the firefights were traumatic the
firefights and this is going to upset a
lot of people the firefights were fun
it's the biggest draw she'll ever get
it's what we love my drama comes from
failing my lads my trauma comes from
seeing a lot of dead bodies that she'll
be dead the younger man look like he
looked death in the eyes
I would normally say no other answer
this because the answer that I want to
give but I'm gonna give it a go I'm good
I'm gonna give it a go at answering it
and looking death in the eyes a lot of
people will think that that means like
on a war field was on it that when
you're fighting the enemy and the
enemy's firing at you or the enemy's
comin at ya
in one way shape her and of Earth and
you think that's deaf I'm looking death
in the eyes I'm faith in the Deaf it's
to me it's not looking death in the eyes
was looking up my my lads injured um dad
that was looking death in the eyes
nothing to see them go or not being able
to help them because you want to be on
the you want to be on the stretcher you
don't want them there you'd rather when
you see your men allowed to get injured
you instantly say I wish I was them
especially with Afghan I was 23 when I
was an Afghan and and lads that were get
injured and killed we're 18 19 so even
though they're a few years younger than
me they were still mine my kids if you
like I needed to protect them and when
you can't protect them yeah that's what
death is
what is truly worse than the pits of
hell at least men like this at
rock-bottom the heads are all over the
place
they're afraid anxious and depressed
PTSD is the most devastating mental
health disorder by far rock bottom when
I was at my worst I was always drinking
that's why I pretty much left the
country because I was a massive burden
on my family in my eyes I didn't want
them to see what I was becoming so with
the drink and the fight and then the
arguing and everyone was an enemy
everything was a threat yeah it resulted
in a few suicide attempts the first one
was driving a me car at a 90 miles an
hour
take me belt off and go into a Sun stone
wall and I won't I hit the windscreen
that was my first attempt and that just
made me more angry because it didn't
work that's rock bomb that was my rock
bomb how the housemates who served in
Afghanistan he used to wake up screaming
came home from work one day to find the
suicide note because he couldn't take it
anymore I visit his grave every year
still gets to me I couldn't help him I
can relate to that because I lost two
very good friends from suicide 2018 John
Paul Finnegan and Kev Williams Katt
Williams when first I didn't speak to
him for two days because the stairs
didn't and then I come back I come back
online he was gone
I blame myself for his passing because
when he needed me it wasn't there but
then when I tried to commit suicide it
doesn't matter who I thought about he
was speaking to me or who was there
I wanted to go and I didn't want people
to get upset over it because my life was
worthless now my life isn't worthless
sometimes I have thoughts why I don't
act upon them my life isn't worthless
because I've got a family to look after
I've coughing's that people rely on me
to do
flurries and I won't go anywhere now all
right this comments his name says it all
that he likes to play games so I'll see
either he's a veteran of the PlayStation
it feels like the old vet is actually a
man I'm the young glad is a [ __ ] no
offense poor he kept talking about
mental health and BS so immense loss yes
the old man served in World War two and
did not complain once if he can't handle
death in a war then don't go in the army
I don't know where to start with this
yeah it's all about mental health
because mental health is killing our
forces it's killing our people
so nobility on civilians so when you've
got the old man is actually a man
doesn't all about at once the reason he
doesn't talk about it is because maybe
doesn't know how to talk about it and
the people like him that are my age that
don't talk about mental health because
they don't want to be a [ __ ] they then
software and then they kill themselves
because they think that they're being a
[ __ ] by itself in the body and a lot BS
so to blow my own trumpet to blow my own
bugle and blow smoke up my own I'm the
opposite to a [ __ ] because I'm actually
talking about it and because I want to
help people become stronger no I can't
handle death and a war in a war and if
you can bring me one person and the
whole British Army that can say to me I
can handle death in war and good on you
because the foolish because death is an
unnatural thing to witness and to see it
a human body in such horrific in such a
horrific form and be all right about it
if you got something wrong you need help
if I replied to that on YouTube by the
way because I'm gonna go on there and
I'm gonna give him and why is the
younger guy dressed like he's about to
work out well now our cargo pants on and
I was covered in oil somewhere so Cheers
anymore I'm gonna roll now have some
respect take off your cap and now we're
going bald sorry you missing the points
you know I mean you're not like sitting
there going oh this is amazing it's it's
great that these two veterans of like
from different generations are come
together and chattin and there might be
helping each other or whatever it's like
oh my god I don't like his Jack here I
was this is invoke swivel I mean as it's
I don't think the old chap knew what
mental health was complete disagree with
I think that's a little rubbish to be
honest yes Jon doesn't know what mental
health Fair's because he's been fighting
it in his own mind he's been fighting
his own demons and you watched the video
he talked about it took him up to 40
years to forgive the Germans 40 years of
your life is a long time to be an angle
of someone like I've only been angry and
anger with not with my enemy but with
myself the 12 years 12 years of hating
myself and loathe myself 40 years of
your life it's a long time so asked us
to kwame up dollars both hairos amazing
for them to talk and potentially help
people go through PTSD or other mental
health issues as a result of war good I
like to think they went to the pub
afterwards yeah we yeah we stayed in
touch we keeping in touch a spokesman v
they and I were but we're just organized
and to me talk very soon and there
hopefully go to the pub whoever I can
keep all of them I don't know and there
is a lot more to talk about
gonna cry let's cry when I get angry
it's got angry people we need to get it
out I mean I'm having venting and
talking is the best
is probably the best remedy shorty has
put the discussion about nurses are on
the agenda than it's been for several
years and again again people seem to
default they talk about the health
service and they talk about beds and
doctors often and yet you say when I was
at the RCN there are lots of beds in
John Lewis across the road